Abe, the
UAW member, excuse me,
are now officially on strike.
You can hear the horns right now.
You are there in Wayne, Michigan,
where the UAW
president John Thain
and other members
are already on the picket line.
What is the mood
like where you are right now?
This is very significant.
It is its history.
It's the first time we have seen
this simultaneous strike
against the big three automakers
in the United States
where outside a Ford plant right now.
And you can probably hear that energy.
It has been a bit chaotic here
the last few minutes.
Hundreds of people
flowing in
to be on this initial strike line.
You can see it behind me.
This is history playing out.
Now I want to bring in
it was Ashley, is that right?
Amanda excuse me, Amanda Sinclair.
Amanda.
Amanda, you work on the box line.
You said that, right? Yes.
Okay.
So you are now on strike
along with about 3000
other people
who work here at the factory.
Tell me how you're feeling tonight.
I feel it's worth
being out here on strike
because we need more money.
Like the cost of living. It went up.
So that's why I'm out here.
I just got off work,
and I came out here to strike.
You were working
until just a few minutes ago.
Yeah, you know.
And what to you
in this negotiation is most important.
What are you looking for?
You cost the living more money.
No, we have everything that we ask for
as of tomorrow.
It seems you're going to be on a
strike pay.
Is that your understanding?
Making about $100 a day?
Yeah. That's not enough at all. Yeah.
How are you going to get by?
And how long are you ready to be
on that picket line? Fighting.
Making only $100 a day.
I don't know how I survive,
but I'm going to do it.
I'm a B, I hear here striking.
Well, thank you so much
for your time, Amanda. Appreciate it.
And again,
if you look behind me, Laura,
this is what history looks like.
Hundreds of people we know
there are 3000 members
who are going to be striking
at this location, just one of three.
There's also a GM plant
in Waynesville, Missouri,
and a Stellantis plant in Toledo, Ohio,
between the three, about 13,000 members.
The question
is, Laura,
how much of a disruption
is that going to cause
to the auto
manufacturing industry
here in the United States?
Because obviously,
when cars can't be finished,
if certain parts can't be made,
it could shut the whole process down
across the country.
There's concern about that
and about the economic impacts.
But that's not what tonight is about.
As you can hear.
You can hear the
energy people who are excited
and it seems like they are ready for this
to potentially last a while.
How long is a mystery?
It just started about,
as you know, 2 minutes ago.
I mean, just thinking
about the significance
when you just spoke
to coming off of work
prepared now
to strike waiting,
she says
perhaps as long as it would take to get
what is owed to them in belief,
using the phrase that it seems
to be worth it to do so.
13,000 members
I mean, there are these three locations
now across the country.
Are the major automakers game
saying anything tonight
about now where we are on strike
Well, look, we've
heard from the president of Ford today.
We know there has been frustration
from these automakers
who feel like
the union
has waited,
has not negotiated in good faith
that they have offered
large pay increases up to 20%.
We know the union is seeking 40%,
but it seems like
there is still a wide gap between them.
Listening to these car companies
talk tonight
and basically say
they have come to the table.
But as of now,
there is
seems to have been little progress.
Laura.
I mean, they're talking a lot
about these tiers, people
who are being working
in the same positions,
getting paid at different amounts,
hoping to end that.
Of course,
just looking at the energy
behind you game since you've arrived,
it has increased
almost exponentially
in the size of the crowd behind you.
Drivers going by honking,
likely in support
of what is happening right now.
And by the way,
we did
invite the three executives
from all three of the auto companies.
They have declined to join us tonight.
We're going to keep checking back
with you.
Stay there and keep us informed
about what's happening on the ground.
Joining me
now is Congresswoman Haley Stevens,
a Michigan Democrat
who supports the strikers
Congresswoman Stevens,
they are officially on strike.
It happened moments ago.
It is historic.
And you are standing in solidarity
with the UAW members
How significant is this strike?
Well, you've got that right.
I'm absolutely standing alongside
the hard
working men and women of the UAW.
And I want to thank Gabe
for being out with the workers striking,
I think a man.
This story is incredibly significant,
a woman who just got off her shift
and who's
now joined the picket line saying
I want a better deal.
And the American people
have to understand,
it's not easy to strike.
It is nerve wracking.
A lot is put on the line.
But the outcome of this
has got to be a better deal
for the workers.
And that's what we're seeing play out.
That's why we're in this position.
And I'm going to be standing
by the UAW through and through.
I mean, just the anxiety in you.
And I'm so glad
that you mentioned the
human element of this
as we're talking a lot
about manufacturing,
where it's going to be
in terms of the economy and areas around
what how will impact the big three
for every person who is on this line?
Every person
contemplating whether to strike
has to consider
exactly what you're talking about,
what it will mean to them immediately
over the next days or weeks.
Perhaps even months ahead
and what it was like over
the next four years.
Thank you for bringing
that to our attention and reminding us.
Congresswoman,
also, though, among the UAW demands
is a 40% pay increase
over a four year period.
It also includes the restoration
of cost
of living pay, raises a 32 hour work
with 40 hours of pay.
Are these fair asks?
Well, I'm certainly not
in the negotiating board room,
but I think it's very fair
for the workers to ask for their fair
share.
And I want to be crystal
clear about what's taking place
right now.
Three plants
between the big three in three
different states are on strike.
There is oftentimes
no question from large automakers
when they decide to permanently
close plants.
We've seen
that happen in droves over the last ten,
15 years.
Dozens of plants shutting down.
This is continued to happen
in the industrial Midwest
while record profits
are received by the large companies.
And I'm proud of Michigan manufacturers.
I'm so proud of the moment we're in.
We were the ones
who rose
to the industrial call to action
during the pandemic.
We've continued to grow in industry
out of it and manage bankruptcy
that I worked on in President
Obama's administration.
I saw the UAW
make concessions
alongside many stakeholders.
And now it's time to get fair share.
A strike is painful,
but the outcome
and the long term
benefits of this
not just for the workers
but for our economy
as a whole, are on the horizon.
Really important
also that the Ford CEO, Jim Farley,
spoke earlier
and talked about a 40% pay raise, saying
that a 40% pay raise
would actually bankrupt his company.
Of course, a common retort
to that is, well,
what about the pay raises?
People like yourself
and your position would actually get?
What's your reaction to his comment
that this could potentially bankrupt this
these industries?
Well, Ford has made billions of dollars,
tens of billions of dollars
in just the first six months
of this year.
So I somewhat question
the bankruptcy consideration,
but certainly we
we want to have a Ford Motor Company.
We will continue to have a Ford
Motor Company.
And I encourage everyone to continue
to negotiate in good faith.
We're seeing some signs of progress
when we hear
that the companies are willing
to meet on increased wages.
But the tears that the
the tier system
that the UAW is asking for.
Certainly COLA
bringing COLA back, which was
got a
negotiated as off the table 14 years ago.
We'd like to see that come back in.
And again, I'm not negotiating this deal,
but I am standing by the UAW
and I think people should listen to Mr.
Van right now
and what he's pushing forward,
see him
with the UAW workers
who are shaking his hand,
who are appreciating someone
who's of the UAW working alongside
his brothers and sisters
and not just shaking hands
with politicians or other VIPs.
He's doing this
just like what you're seeing
at the Wayne assembly plant
in Michigan here tonight.